[Applause]
oh
how do you do
I'm ready I am Tom shallou in for Greg
Gutfeld it is Friday you know what that
means let's welcome tonight's guests his
jokes make great compost
founder of the loftusparty.com Michael
Loftis
[Applause]
she's my favorite Austin since Steve
host of The Hoop chat Emily Austin
he's as delicious as the egg dish he's
named for comedian and host of that rock
show on YouTube Jim Glory Days
she's a real catch according to Interpol
Fox News contributor Kat Tim
okay before we get to some news stories
let's do this
Greg's leftovers
yes it's leftovers I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and just like Greg
this is my first time reading these here
we go
this week rapper Eminem sent a cease and
desist letter to keep Vivek ramaswamy
from using his song Lose Yourself
lawyers also filed an injunction to
prevent Chris Christie from calling
himself Slim Shady
all right
all right hey why not while on tour in
Montgomery Alabama cat temp was
approached by a lesbian who gave her her
phone number
oh cat declined and instead invited her
to the show tonight
that was a Greg joke that was Greg's I
think and I'm so happy right now
last weekend climate change Fanatics
blocked Burning Man fans from getting to
the festival grounds it was the largest
gathering of annoying white people this
side of the Vermont primaries
all right Bernie a Turkish Airline is
offering customers the option to sit in
a kid-free section for an additional fee
the good news for kids is the new
children's section will allow smoking
kid you've got a good view there
specialty seating is catching on across
the industry for an extra 50 bucks
American Airlines will let you choose if
you want to sit next to that
who's not real
[Applause]
wow I committed to that one
pediatricians and parents are calling
for a ban on energy drinks that can have
six times as much caffeine as Coca-Cola
I think that's good I can't imagine
anyone who'd need that much caffeine
the annual World gravy wrestling
championship was held on Monday in
England while the event is popular with
wrestling fans it's far more popular
with fans of gravy
Joe Biden invited the WNBA Champion Las
Vegas Aces to the White House but then
he didn't show up luckily WNBA players
are used to people not showing up
[Applause]
Amanda Nebraska was pulled over in a
modified car that had a full-size bull
restrained in the passenger side but
some are speculating Omaha Stakes ran
out of dry ice
wow wow don't go after
don't go after the animals on this show
This Week ABC revealed the 22 women who
will be competing on the first ever
senior citizen golden Bachelor
and during their interviews many
contestants say they've fallen in love
and can't get up
that's the good
good for this crowd a new poll finds 77
percent of Americans think Joe Biden is
too old for a second term but Democrats
say the president is as energetic and
quick on his feet as FDR
and when asked about that poll the most
Americans agree that Biden doesn't have
a second term in him the president
replied that makes all of us
yeah
all right
now to the news suddenly the Pentagon
wants us to know whenever there's a UFO
this week the government launched a
website for its all domain anomaly
resolution office or Arrow where you can
check out Declassified videos pictures
and reports of UFOs without the usual
only fans fees
the Pentagon describes it as a One-Stop
shop for all publicly available
information related to UAP UAP or
unidentified aerial phenomena the site
compiles a bunch of videos of mysterious
flying objects before they're killed by
offshore windmills
the site will also allow service members
to submit when what they think might be
alien sightings as for everyday
Americans a pentagon spokesman says it's
something they'll look into in the
future there's also a global hotspot map
showing where the most UFO reports have
originated the Persian Gulf Far East
Asia and the U.S coasts including
Washington DC which does make sense I
mean this guy works there
[Music]
the UAP right there
okay so uh what do you guys think of
this I mean I'll go to ucat this this
UFO thing do you think
that the government is trying to
distract us from other other things oh
there you go that's what you were going
to say right well well what I okay I had
a lot to say but I will keep it brief as
I it's not just you and I here Tom I
want to be rude
um so I think the narrative around it
has been very interesting because I've
seen so many memes and so many people
say that well the government's talking
about how there could be aliens and like
nobody even cares that there's aliens
it's like that's not what's going on
what's going on is that nobody cares in
the well what what's it looks like that
because people just don't care that the
government is saying it because
everything I mean it's just true that
everything the government tells us is
based on whatever its own agenda is yeah
so if the government's like we're going
to tell you this stuff about aliens it's
like okay
cool because you are it's not like
they're going to give us anything that
juicy because they're the government
right so there's something else going on
what is your theory Jim as to why the
government would be wanting us to look
at UFOs when they wanted us to not look
at it for so many years right well
because that whistleblower came out a
couple months ago and revealed all this
stuff and then six Senators said Hey
listen we're coming after you sending
the Pentagon goes okay we're going to
set up this website we're going to let
you know yeah everything that's going on
and you know the American people like
Kat said don't even believe anything the
government does now now we're going to
believe the website okay now all the
truth is going to be on the website
if you're going to classify stuff like
they said they're gonna have to classify
everything to classify like cool stuff
like you know what politician would be
an alien
I go with Kamala Harris because there's
no way a human could speak in circles
like that
only an alien yeah could just speak
around like that but and she's really
into the moon right she's always talking
about the moon
I didn't think about that that's true
yeah and I think if this thing takes off
maybe they could you know open like a
big uh make an amusement park at Area 51
in Roswell to take pictures with the
aliens go up in the spaceship
yeah a museum right yeah maybe I think
people want to see that Emily welcome to
the show thank you yeah first timer
first timer Emily do you think they know
more than they're telling us and if they
do what's their motive
well first of all for you to now tell me
that they're not really life beings
they're just probably these like blob of
cells that they're calling
extraterrestrial or like activity that's
pretty sad because I don't really tell
people this but I actually wanted to be
an astronaut when I was older and one of
the things yeah I know I know
please I didn't stick with it but um
you know
settle down there
decided not to of course I couldn't
pursue my dreams because my mom said no
and um you know I'd love to see some
aliens but you know sadly the older you
get and you start to learn things it's
not all fun and games and as much as I'm
happy to now see there's something out
there
I'm smart enough to know that it's
probably a distraction for something
bigger going on right here on our turf
and they just want to shift the
attention away so I'd like to be happy
about it but the the smarter side of me
is like all right what's Hunter doing
yeah
Michael don't you wish you had a smarter
side of you
every day and I try to hold on to that
thought and then it just poof goes away
uh I don't know what's going on I want
the aliens to be real right and I think
they have good intentions if they're
gonna do something bad they already
would have done it right and if it's the
government trying to distract this it's
a pretty good distraction I like the
videos and all that stuff here's what I
know I don't want the probes to stop
like uh I go on these camping trips and
I I'm paralyzed and in comes an alien
and they know exactly what I like so uh
if it's the military or either way just
keep the good stuff coming there E.T so
how
many times a day we know we think of Ash
sorry I'm thinking about astronauts um
do they think like they call their
parents and are like I told you so
because every kid probably tells their
parents they want to be an astronaut
you're like okay honey but some people
do do it I checked astronaut in my
little uh you know wish book when I was
a kid yeah and here I am thinking I'm
like so cool
one day or whatever I'm not special I
guess yeah no I I think that was it was
it was a good it was a good thing Emily
you know I here's my theory the
globalists right they want to globalize
the world and so they but everybody
needs an enemy so it's like nationalists
they you know they think other countries
are bad you know but when they destroy
all the borders and we have a one world
government they want to keep us uh you
know thinking that the aliens are the
enemy what do you think of that Jim
um I don't believe it you know I don't
know I don't know I mean look I I wanted
to be an astronaut too I only checked it
off
because it was the first thing on the
list that it began with an a
H but I don't know yeah it's weird that
like Michael said that they don't mess
with us like they hover around and then
they just take off you think that they
would mess with us and do something yeah
I mean are they afraid of us I don't
know well that's it they probably don't
mess with you because you don't go
camping like he did they always show
them at the campsites right and
sometimes they're late and I'm like come
on you guys I'm ready
did I actually come in the tent or did
or no sometimes the ten sometimes
nothing yeah
before we go I'm touring my new one-man
show spontaneous combustion come see me
at hyenas in Fort Worth on October 14th
and the Hobby Center in Houston on
October 15th tickets are available now
go to tomsallute.com